How...have you
lived in London for so long...
and never learned to
ride a bike?
Okay, so I did know
when I was, like, this tall.
Apparently.
I have no memory of it.
I am told that my folks got me
to the point where it's like,
"Yes, child can ride bike. Tick."
Yeah.
You can't forget
how to ride a bike, can you(?)
So yeah, we moved somewhere
where I didn't need to ride a bike.
And then I never got a bike.
And then it's 30 years later.
I don't know how to ride a bike.
Well...
I've just forgotten.
Well, this— we're not too far away
from where I learned to ride a bike.
Okay.
...26 years ago.
(laughs)
Yeah. We're also
not too far away
from where you learned
to ride a bike up stairs...
and where you learned
to do track stands...
to do basically everything.
Well, I admire you
for doing this, because...
you know, padding out
and coming out in public, and stuff.
Oh, it's flat-out embarrassing.
This is something I should have known.
This is a basic skill
that I should have.
You shouldn't be embarrassed,
because it's admirable, what you're doing.
Everyone should learn
to ride a bike.
Yeah.
It's easy...
and it will improve your life.
Just say it's easy(!)
I think you're gonna get this
in a matter of hours.
Smash cut to, like,
ten minutes later, in a hospital(!)
I think you are gonna fall.
That's why I've got the gear.
But you're gonna be going so slow that
hopefully it won't be serious.
And if it is serious, then...
we've got it on camera, so.
This is a Deviate Highlander,
with 150 mm travel in the back,
160 mm in front.
I fitted nice mud tires for you,
just in case you're shredding...
in the mud and you need that extra grip.
Right, okay. Yeah.
Totally gonna try and do
a skidding stop here(!)
We've got you a dropper post,
which means you can adjust
your seat height on the fly.
And the only thing
I would say about this bike
that is different from
anything you've ridden
is the brakes are, like,
super sharp.
Okay.
Try to use one finger, if you can.
Right.
And, when you freak out,
just try to be wary of...
going for the bar like that.
Of going like that, yeah.
What I would actually suggest is,
if you just wheel it back and forward...
Yeah, alright.
...and pull the front brake.
I've seen a friend of mine go,
just doing an emergency stop, and just...
Yeah.
Yeah. So...
Do not particularly want to go
to the hospital with three broken teeth.
...Yeah, not kidding!
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
See, you're gonna want to grab
a handful of brake when you freak out.
Yes I am(!)
But just try to be mindful.
Alright.
Yeah.
Do you know what the difference is
between the two brakes on the bike?
One is front wheel,
one is back wheel.
Do you know which one's which?
Which one's wh— No.
I know if you pull the front wheel,
you're more—
If you pull the front one, you're way more likely
to go forward over the...
Yeah.
So...
Which one's which?
So, your right—
In the UK, we're in the UK...
This is different in Europe
than America, so just...
Right.
In the UK, the right-hand brake
is your front wheel,
and the left-hand is the back.
So I should try and pull left if I can?
Ideally, you would gently pull
both brakes in an even manner, right?
But I understand that
you're gonna be freaking out,
and you're gonna just
grab a handful.
So maybe today,
if you just kept your hand,
this hand, like,
closed-grip like that,
and then this hand like that...
One finger on the brake.
Then no matter what happens,
you're not gonna go over the front.
Alright!
'Kay, so right hand closed.
Yeah. One finger.
Left hand, one finger.
Okay? So yeah.
Alright.
I would put your seat
all the way down.
Yes! Thank you.
So...
And if you just sit on the bike,
and don't do anything...
and just see.
I just gotta... okay.
Alright, so...
So even if you freak out,
your feet can touch the ground.
I can put my feet down. Alright.
What I would do first is just
do what a toddler does.
Okay. Cry and scream(!)
On one of those balance bikes.
Just waddle along
without the pedals.
Just to get a feel for
how the bike rolls.
Oh, bloody hell.
Alright, yeah, okay.
Yeah!
Okay!
So if you could maybe pick up
enough speed to sort of begin rolling.
Alright.
Okay.
(titters) Okay, okay!
Yeah.
Alright.
Wait, you haven't done the catchphrase!
Oh yeah, okay.
We can do it.
Do you want me to do it now?
Yeah, go for it.
Alright, this is Tom's
day one, hour zero.
♪ (lighthearted indie pop)
Alright, speed up, speed up,
speed up, speed up, speed up.
(titters and cackles)
(choking groans)
There we go.
♪ (music stops)
Alright, no, that—
(laughs)
I felt like I had a moment
there where it worked!
So the initial hump you want to
overcome is the speed.
The slower you go,
the more unstable you'll be.
I mean, you understand that we're working
with basically a gyroscope?
Yeah, so the faster I go...
Yeah, and that's the initial—
But the faster you go,
the more scary it is.
Yeah!
So try to get a feel for
that gyroscopic effect
by trying to waddle along
until the speed's high enough,
so you start feeling that stability.
Okay.
Speed, speed, bit more speed.
Yeah, yeah. That's right, that's right.
Bit more speed, bit more speed.
That's it! You feel it hovering.
I felt like I was permanently
balancing left there!
That's it, cool.
Yes, that's it.
(grunts desperately)
That was cool!
That's it, you're getting it!
It's actually easier
once I'm not waddling along!
Yeah, can I give you a push?
...Sure!
If I hold your shoulders...
Yeah.
and you lift your feet
just an inch off the ground...
Oh, that's terrifying.
Yeah.
Yeah okay, there's
no balance there at all.
Okay, so we're just gonna waddle along,
and I'm gonna try and hold you up.
Yep.
Take your feet off the ground.
Ooh, nope!
I've got you though. I've got you.
I've got you. There we go.
So then, get a feel for that
gyroscopic effect.
Okay, okay.
Cool.
Oh no!
Yeah, there we go.
Oh-oh-ayy!
There we go, yeah!
So you see how you steered there...
Yeah.
and you kinda got a feel for
steering the opposite way?
And then I went
completely the wrong way.
Yeah, okay.
I mean, I kinda wanna jump ahead
and try pedaling at this point.
So what to do is...
Yeah?
Put the pedal up to here...
Okay.
and do a little half-crank.
Like, as in just crank to there,
and then take your feet off.
And just see
where the bike goes.
So just, like, half-pedal?
Yeah so, let me grab my bike.
Okay.
If you just do a little half-crank...
you can feel
how the pedal affects the bike.
Okay.
Yeah.
I was about to say, "You make that look easy,"
but that is the most basic skill.
Like, any human makes that look easy.
But if you can do the half-crank,
and then just coast...
then you'll get comfortable
with doing a full-crank.
(blabbers) Yeah.
Yeah.
So try and do that,
but try to stay up.
Yeah.
Thank you(!)
(laughs)
Give that a push. There we go.
Ooh, okay.
(yelps)
Yes, yes!
Yes.
There was a second there!
So all you have to do is link together
that first and second crank.
That's the same as juggling.
Yeah, yeah.
Juggling, you throw
the first ball,
and you learn throw, catch,
throw, catch, throw, catch.
And it's that bit—
And you do two, and two's fine.
and then you put the third one in,
and it all falls apart,
until something switches in your brain,
and you figure it, okay.
Nice.
(yelps)
Ahem, that didn't happen.
(snickers)
Yes.
I'm getting there.
He's got balls.
This guy's got balls.
I'm very aware of that,
thanks to the saddle(!)
(cackles)
Yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes!
Ohh!
I looked up...
and you know what that was?
I didn't looking at
what my feet were doing,
and I just— something
in my brain went, "Look up."
Perfect.
"...Oh, okay!"
See, you're doing
that bit naturally, yeah.
'Cause the tendency
is to look down,
but if you look up,
your balance is better.
Good, good, good.
...Not that good. (laughs)
But the commitment was good.
I appreciate the kind words(!)
I'm not sure—
Can I try something?
I'm going to increase
your gear ratio...
so that one pedal stroke
will propel you further.
Okay. Yeah, go for it.
I think you're getting stuck.
So I'll just ask you to
step off the bike for a second.
I'm gonna go down—
I'm gonna go up two gears.
Okay.
So yeah, your ratio will be higher now.
Alright.
'Kay.
So, when I put my foot down,
I'm gonna go further.
But it's gonna be harder for me
to put my foot down.
Exactly. You'll feel that immediately.
Okay.
Yes I will!
Yeah.
That's it, that's it!
Oh! Whoa-kay!
That was...
For like, half a second,
I had that.
By the way, this...
this is is continuing until
one of three things happens.
One, I learn to ride a bike.
Two, I'm in hospital.
Or three, the rainstorm
that has been threatening
for the last few hours
suddenly arrives.
Right, when you're ready,
I'm just here to stabilise you.
Okay.
♪ (lighthearted indie pop)
That's it. That's it.
That's it.
That's it. (laughs)
(grunts)
Keep going, keep going.
Keep pedaling, keep pedaling.
Keep pedaling.
Yes, that's it.
♪ (music ends)
(tittles)
(laughs)
That didn't work!
Hang on a sec.
I think you were actually—
'Cause the grass allows you
more freedom to mess around,
maybe we should go to
a lighter gear and just work on that.
Let's do that.
While you're doing that...
I'm gonna take this sweater off.
Yeah.
Okay. Right.
Nope.
(both laugh)
There we go, there we go.
We're up, we're up, we're up.
Right, let's get some speed up.
There we go, there we go.
Steer into it, into it.
I did what I was doing.
And then you said, "Steer into it,"
and my brain went...
"Oh, he must mean
the other way!"
Okay, we're going uphill here.
This is gonna be hard.
Yes, that's it!
That's it! That's totally it!
(laughs hysterically)
Keep pedaling, keep pedaling.
Oh no.
(chuckles)
Here we go.
Right, yeah. Keep pedaling.
Keep pedaling, keep pedaling,
keep pedaling, keep pedaling.
That's it, that's it.
Oh! (cackles)
That's it!
Keep pedaling, keep pedaling,
just keep pedaling.
Keep pedaling,
I'm trying!
I can't—
You've got time.
You've got time to think.
Now put your feet on the pedals.
And keep pedaling.
There we go.
Okay. Agh, no.
Turn into it, turn into it.
We wanna go that way.
(groans loudly)
(chuckles)
So there's moments where
I'm not even really touching you.
So let's start on the tarmac
in a bigger gear.
Yeah.
And then we'll go faster,
and you'll feel that stability.
The bike will ride itself.
You don't need to...
No it bloody won't(!)
Oh, watch.
Like, it rides itself.
You make a solid point.
Yeah, yeah.
But only at-speed.
By the way, I have...
I have a goal now.
'Cause I know your videos
tend to aim for a goal.
There to pagoda.
I think that's an admirable goal.
There we go. Oh yes.
Just get familiar with that speed.
There we go.
(shrieks)
(laughs triumphantly)
He's riding a bike!
Stop the clock! Stop the clock!
I'm riding a bike! Yes!
That was awesome!
Did you notice?
I mean, it was wobbly as hell!
It was wobbly as hell,
but I felt your hands go away.
And the thing
I had to crack was...
turning into the... into it.
Yeah.
Okay, okay!
So, do you want to try
without me at all?
Or do you still want me to—
'Cause I notice you're
a lot more successful
when your feet are on the pedals
before you start.
Yeah.
It seems like the biggest hurdle
you're having is actually
keeping your shoes on the pedals.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I think you're thinking
too much about your feet.
They will just find themselves.
They haven't been so far, but...
Alright, okay, yep.
(laughs joyfully)
(both laugh)
Yes! Okay, we're good.
That was awesome.
Thank you. Thank you there,
because what happened was...
I was like, "I'm fine, I'm fine.
I have lost the pedals!
"I don't know where they are."
You know what I forgot?
The brake!
So when you lose the pedals,
you've got more time than you think.
You can take your time, you can breathe,
and you can find them again.
Alright.
We're getting up to speed now,
where you have to cover the brake.
Yes.
The bike was— The bike was
choosing the direction there.
But like, I lost my balance,
and we were going that way.
No falls, though!
...Don't say that!
(laughs)
But it's good.
You got your braking.
You've got your steering.
You've got your pedaling.
Like, we're good.
(titters)
I don't know why I keep
going to the right, but I do!
So I think it could be worth
putting the seat up a bit.
You think?
Because what's happening is
your feet are coming up, right?
And they're really compressing
to get out of the way.
So if you look at me, it's like...
you have to kinda bring them up.
Whereas if the seat was here,
it's a much more natural position.
Alright.
So I've put up maybe four inches.
I mean, I don't love it.
It looks better.
It does, but I'm just worried
about my ability to reach the floor?
Right, there we go.
Oh, that's so much better.
Yep, yep.
Yes, yes.
Yes!
I mean, I'm not really in control
on my direction yet.
That is amazing!
Yes!
You had, like, 20 minutes!
Have it!
Please tell me he remembers
which one's the brake.
(snickers) Oh god.
He's totally got it.
Wahey!
(cackles)
Yes!
That was your goal?
We're not there yet...
because I was trying to get
'round the pagoda and back.
But... that felt better.
Yes, he's starting on his— look at him
starting on his own, no problem.
Yes, this is amazing!
(grumbles) We're going
this way now!
Didn't intend to, but we are!
Alright, here we go, here we go.
I'm gonna try and line—
No, no,
no, no, no.
(laughs)
Good save on the camera.
Alright.
You started on your own there,
without even complaining about it.
Yeah, I actually didn't think about that.
Here we go.
No-o-o-okay!
Yeah, no.
Alright!
Alright, here we go.
Come on. No, keep your feet on the pedals,
keep your feet on the pedals.
Keep your feet on the pedals.
Look forward, look forward.
This is incredible.
Balance.
I'm gonna try a left turn.
Oh my god,
he's actually going 'round it!
Left turn, left turn,
left turn, come on.
Yes!
Yes...!
That's it.
Left, come on.
Go left, go left,
go left, there we—
(stammers and groans)
No! Nearly!
There was a divot in the grass
that sent me slightly off,
and it was all
downhill from there!
So I think we can go up
another two gears?
I feel like we can—
I feel like we can do that.
Yeah, 'cause there's a maximum speed
that this gear can go.
So we'll bump up another two,
so you'll need another
harder push to get going.
Alright...
What I can't explain is...
why my arms
are the most tired part of me.
Legs, doing absolutely fine.
But I think I'm just
holding myself like... solid.
I think you're just a bit stiff.
So I need to loosen up a bit.
But you've got it.
I mean, you've got it.
Once I get back,
I'm getting 'round that gazebo
and I'm coming back.
Cool.
I'm not even following you
anymore. Is that okay?
Yeah, that's fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh my god, starts like a pro.
Oh, that feels better!
Yes, he's in the middle gear now.
Finger on the brake,
just in case.
We're on a nice, wide
left turn.
There we go. Look where
you want to go, look—
Oh, I remember that!
Yes.
Yes, Tom.
Look at the speed.
He's absolutely nailed it.
Yes!
Stop the clock!
(giggles) That's how we do it!
Yes! Well done!
How'd you feel?
I'm—
That was incredible!
I'm... I'm out of breath.
I'm... very...
yeah, okay.
Oh, that felt good.
That felt really good.
I mean, looking at you,
you wouldn't think that you just learned.
You just look like
another guy in London.
That was... 30-odd minutes.
Thank you, Mike. That...
I'm looking at a subscription to, like,
the London cycle hire scheme now.
Yeah.
'Cause...
I'm not gonna try cycling
on roads anytime soon, but...
I need to go learn
in parks now, right?
I'm over the embarrassment bit.
Yeah.
In front of however many
thousands of people watching, but...
I mean, if you can put on
those elbow pads...
you're immune to embarrassment.
(cackles)
That's fair... but ouch!
Well done, I'm gobsmacked.
If only my videos were that quick(!)
♪ (upbeat music)
That was a turn!
I was just able to slow down!
I don't know how I did it.
I just stopped pedaling!
♪ (music stops)
Oh (bleep)!
D'oh, there we go!
We got (indistinct)!
Are you alright, man?
I'm fine!
But I'm really glad
I had the elbow pads!
[Caption+ by JS*
https://caption.plus]
That's it!
Mike, that's a wrap.
We're done!